How much does my attitude affect my cancer really? I think that's how much does my cancer?
How much does my attitude really affect my health or my cancer? Well, I think it affects
your body a lot. If you're talking about just a good attitude, bad attitude, happy,
crabby, you know, I think there's a lot of biblical reference to be grateful. And you know,
the, you know, there's a lot of new agey kind of positive mental attitude stuff. But really,
you could argue that it is growing, typically as well. I wouldn't say that there's any
biblical stance that if you just have a good attitude, everything's going to be good. But
it does tell us, typically, that we're supposed to be grateful and thankful for everything.
The fruits of the spirit, our love, joy, peace, patience, goodness, kindness,
gratefulness, self-control. These are all outward acts. The fruit of the spirit is the fruit that
comes from a tree that's grounded in God. So if we're grounded in our Father, in our Heavenly Father,
then we're going to bear good fruit. So I guess I would say that our attitude is the fruit
of what we're grounded in. So if I am, you know, I have a day that I'm crabby and angry,
which I have a lot of days like that. I have to look at what am I holding on to? Is it the situate?
Is it my positive situation that's going to make me happy? Or am I grounded in my relationship with
Jesus Christ through Jesus Christ to my Heavenly Father that's going to give me joy? That's going to
bear the fruit that we call our attitude. You know, when I have a bad attitude, I got to look at
where where my groundedness is. Am I really grafted into the tree of our Heavenly Father?
That's the question I have to ask myself. When we need to all be introspective enough,
and we need to all have close enough friends and in loved ones in our life that can
slap us a little bit and we need to all not take offense, but we do have some wood in our life that
loves us enough to slap us a little bit to remind us of where we're supposed to be grafted into
and grounded into and so that we will produce the fruit of the spirit in our lives.
And that's what accountability is and that's what, you know, spiritual maturity is,
is, you know, said many times, spiritual maturity isn't not sitting. It's that we are more quickly
convicted of our sin in our bad attitude and more quickly repent of that bad attitude
and and bring and come back into submission to our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. So
the more I, the longer I take to come back into submission to my to my Lord is a sign of
less maturity. As I mature, doesn't mean I'm not going to screw up more and have a bad attitude
and be frammy. It means that I'll be convicted more quickly and be able to come back into submission.